and there and they can lonely and
they're limiting the amount of people
that can dined within the restaurant
which makes sense right so but it at
least gives them something to look
forward to because a lot of these
businesses are shutting down
for example no more soup plantation
people have said they're like no more
soup plantation I go was the last time
you went there like seven years ago to
in years when I was su plantation to
have such a grasp on our you know high
school was popping for us everybody you
know what is that why [ __ ] it was the
focaccia pizza bread it was the chicken
noodle soup the clam chowder the fries
the all-you-can-eat soft-serve so yeah
okay so Hometown Buffet or Souplantation
wait a super nation ie all-you-can-eat
so Souplantation I think it hit hit the
right wave of when everybody was trying
to get healthy that's when that whole
healthy [ __ ] started happening and
everybody wanted to be a part of that
they were like okay well if I'm gonna be
healthy look at this place it's all
vegetables but lo and behold people
weren't even getting the fresh veggies
they were getting the broccoli cells
which was mayonnaise and vinegar with
apple cider and brown sugar and then
bacon bits and they were getting the
macaroni salad which is pasta and
mayonnaise and then they would go to the
clam chowder and then they would get
focaccia pizza bread and eat it with
that and they thought that they were
making healthy choices right now that
literally was I thought that I was
making healthy choices and I left that
every [ __ ] time no way I don't blame
you because Souplantation was one was
place to be known to like help you when
like subway was like like yeah I was in
that category that foot long in that
veggie sub whatever even just getting
Italian sub for some reason subway
really did a good job
subway trick the [ __ ] out of me man all
the time and I wasn't losing no [ __ ]
yeah exactly but then I used to switch
it up on my own can you scoop out that
bread on the inside as I and I get some
light mail with that and either way that
[ __ ] was still like 800 calories and I
went down two of them cuz I didn't know
what my caloric intake I didn't know
what that [ __ ] is
by scooping up the grass break for more
manis yeah I scooped out the bread and
now I want you squeeze mayonnaise in the
cavity I and then at the death I want
you add olives don't you dare put a
[ __ ] vest and then double up to me
and there's more like excuse me walk out
I'm like I just made a good choice yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah he's a good but Dan you
still only eat that one sandwich and
then not eat anything for the rest of
the day he has some really unhealthy
food habits like he would go up and down
and wait all the [ __ ] time
was it did you ever do a tuna melt with
hot cheetos not you that wasn't me if at
all I don't I don't like tuna melts oh
it's not that I don't like tuna melts is
just that uh I feel like every time I
got wanted tasted like the tin like
subway I I got the stuff that I knew
exactly what I wanted
it's not that I wanted was it was a
turkey avocado and I got it with the
whole wheat bread cuz that's hella
healthier right about the bread light
Mayo I would get spinach no [ __ ]
lettuce pallav the peppers tomatoes
olive oil red vinegar salt and pepper
and that was my healthy one right and
then if I wanted to be even healthier
than that I got the the ham actually had
less calories than the turkey did you
see the people were like up in arms
about musician was really big lost a lot
of weight European British oh no Adele
like [ __ ] she shed more CISOs by the
seashore she my saying right now she
said more weight than she had before it
cuz I'm Rashid oh she had like a little
stint where she lost my last weight and
then she was more weight yeah she lost
in absorbing amount of weight I wasn't
kind of shocked there was a photo of her
where she was just you know standing
next to somebody and she looked a little
worn out and
that was the photo that everybody was
talking about and they were gossiping
about how she lost weight in a very
unhealthy way without even asking her
without even getting a statement about
it yeah man love to bill you up you did
it's it's weird because I've been you
know when I'm on Twitter and stuff and
I'm listening
you could tell what's trending by how
much things pop up there are a few
people that I follow and they're fans of
mine right I follow them not because we
have a connection I follow them because
they are the most basic human beings on
earth and they follow the most basic
tweets so they're the people that keep
me connected to I don't know [ __ ] about
what's going on so when when I know when
they retweet [ __ ] that's what everybody
else's don't have to know yeah so I'm
like okay this is the thing right and so
these about it's like 10 or 15 people
when they all in consensus start
tweeting the same [ __ ] and they have an
opinion about it I must step down I'm
like this is this is what's poppin and
so all of them had a tweet about Adele's
weight loss and some of it was
interesting because that conversation is
going it's number one
okay there's there's this whole hot
topic right now it's about fat phobia
mmm right I had no idea what fat phobia
is right it's like I was like is that a
fear of being fat but what they're
talking about is people people who are
fat phobic or people who look down on
people who are fat or some [ __ ] like oh
yeah it's like the whole fat phobia
thing I mean you guys can write the
actual definition of it I don't really
give a [ __ ] but there's two sides right
it's if you're if you celebrate your
health you're not so much your health if
you celebrate your weight loss if you
celebrate how much you became fit from
how you were before if you're talking
about how you feel great about you know
showing your six-pack abs you're
actually a catalyst to this negative
conversation about people who are who
are overweight and so you're a very fat
phobic person and you're a very bad
person right and there's the other side
where it's like if you are extremely
overweight and you're unhealthy you keep
finding reasons to feel better about
yourself even though you know you're
unhealthy and you're just finding things
and finding information to support your
bad habits and you want other people to
feel bad just like you do kind of like
oh it's culture or the good discussion
about
Liz oh and Cheryl Amina guy was talking
about that Liz oh just like when she
shook her when she shook her ass at the
Staples game Emory was like oh my god I
can you do that yeah you're overweight
and like you're talking about not you
know it's not about fat shaming but I
love my body and I'm healthy and I